huh  i don't know like 20 of them defending  on this the professional still just  gets it in the back of the net  well worth a watch actually  what do you think if magnus had to fight  let's  and nine-year-old kids how many would  you have to send at him in order to  to take him down because he's a strong  guy  three nine year olds he can  defeat for sure let's say ten  if they don't make this typical villain  mistake to attack one at a time yeah  that's they all come at him  i never understood that you know in kill  bill you know she just polished like 50  of them because it was like one by one  yeah that happened a lot in movies like  it's really strange they don't attack  together  yeah  no but they do know but i've seen them  also attacked together but they placed  themselves up and we have a hand designs  and view zones soon enough and that's it  the world champion picks up his second  classical win and